there's a girl out there for all of us
maybe even in this office park there has
to be a way to get all these lonely
people together ned a giant not a giant
net uh what do you have in mind i was
thinking maybe like a mixer oh god
that's a terrible old-fashioned meat
market no i don't think it is lonely
people mixing with one another breeding
creating an even lonelier generation
you're not allowing natural selection to
do its work
you're like the guy invented the seat
belt there's a girl out there for all of
us maybe even in this office park there
has to be a way to get all these lonely
people together annette giant yeah not a
giant net uh what do you have in mind i
was thinking maybe like a mixer oh god
that's a terrible old-fashioned meat
market no i don't think it is lonely
people mixing with one another breeding
creating an even lonelier generation
you're not allowing natural selection to
do its work
you're like the guy invented the seat
belt there's a girl out there for all of
us maybe even in this office park there
has to be a way to get all these lonely
people together annette giant not a
giant net uh what do you have in mind i
was thinking maybe like a mixer oh god
that's a terrible old-fashioned meat
market no i don't think it is lonely
people mixing with one another breeding
creating an even lonelier generation
you're not allowing natural selection to
do its work
you're like that guy invented the seat
belt dwight
you have to listen to me
we are not seeing each other anymore
can you accept that
fine
and i just want to be friends
good
plus a little extra
also i love you
there you go
wait a minute what is this i didn't
order this for you
from them
wow
[Music]
what are you doing man it's not safe
anything could have been in there
nice try
you go you have to go with them i do i
have to go stay you know i have to go
good luck against con college all right
call me
i'm not gonna call him how are you
feeling better no
well you're the cutest button
you worked up quite a sweat the bet is
removing all of sprinkles organs right
now and sending them to the lab
i am a farmer angela what does that mean
okay when a farmer sees an animal that
is in pain that has no quality of life
that has no utility a farmer does what
city folk don't have the stomach to do
you didn't kill her
i i sang her her favorite songs
you put her in my freezer it was
beautiful and gentle and respectful i
fed her antihistamines and she gradually
fell asleep well then she barfed them up
in the freezer and tried to get out well
i'm not responsible for that hey ow
it's okay nothing i'm robbing her it's
nothing it's fine what
could you do that without telling me i
thought i was helping you i expected a
hug
i took care of that cat the best way i
knew how
cat heaven is a beautiful place but you
don't get there if you're euthanized i
know a great taxidermist i'll pay to
have her stuffed well he's not great but
he's pretty good
you don't understand
take back mike seriously don't get bit
or we can have her buried out at the
east field by mother
huh
touch me dwight
are you going not because i want to
of all feelings to base a show around
glee
thirst
now that's a show i'd watch
i would watch that
tonight might be a convenient night for
us to have some intercourse
ever since michael dumped jan for carol
jan's been bitching out on him
reject a woman and she will never let it
go one of the many defects of their kind
also weak arms
hmm
it's quite turkey like
okay i'm just gonna check on dinner
angelo would you like some of my beet
salad i hate beet salad
it's actually really good hey hey hey
i know you love beet salad i've seen you
eat it many times the thought of popping
one of your beets into my mouth makes me
want to vomit
i hate it when girls insist on taking
them out to do restaurants every weekend
night and then they're like when are we
gonna go on a date date i hate that too
i hate that too it sucks it totally
sucks yeah and then they make you drive
them to church the next morning like gas
ain't free
what are you wearing
come on it's a casual social outfit
looks like you're going to a fish fry
dwight no they're howling at the moon
it's suggestive to women because of
howling during sex okay
oh
that's not appropriate oh
uncool uncool dwight
okay okay come on let's go
you have everything
cell phone
charger yeah mm-hmm
so sure you don't want breakfast that's
the most important meal of the day
it really is i'm not hungry i ate a
whole bunch of sunflower seeds after you
went to sleep
and besides i wouldn't want to take you
away from pam on the morning of her
wedding oh she needs you isabelle that's
really sweet dwight
so i'll see you at the wedding you know
it okay
okay get out of here bye okay
hey good morning
it's about damn time i haven't gone to
the bathroom in a day and a half
oh my god dwight this room was a pit
really hadn't noticed too busy knocking
boots
how can you eat like that
i'm raving this after a night of
lovemaking you know
yeah i'm hungry but i'm not gonna make a
pig out of my house hey what was she
like
she was cute you know she was hot she
was very hot
she made love
like a tiger right side or groom side
her townie
she was from europe
no kidding uh-huh i'm not she had hairy
armpits no isabelle was nice but
i hope she doesn't think
this is going anywhere
wait a second you're not into her are
you kidding me
no she's pam's best friend you guys
could double date
swap maybe oh please put a gun in my
mouth no you're crazy look she's a
dental hygienist from carbondale and she
makes love like one she's a bumpkin
she's okay do you know how hard it is to
be a hygienist you have to take x-rays
you have to scrape the plaque off of
people's teeth you have to tell kids
when to spit and make sure that they're
not scared when the dentist comes in it
it
you should ask her out
i already have my european girlfriend
pull over
why
room to the side of the road why
pull
and i don't care that phillip's not my
son i will raise a hundred children
with a hundred of your lovers if it
means i can be with you
can you put that down this expresses how
loudly i love you it's too
loud i want eye contact no yes do you
understand how rare that is in nature i
am not some farm animal
you